hallo mein name ist luca und diesen satz
habe ich in diesem jahr sehr häufig
gesagt über 200 videos habe ich dieses
jahr auf meinem kanal hochgeladen und
darunter auch videos die wirklich krass
viral gegangen sind also über 234
millionen aufrufe erzielt haben die
beispielsweise die glücksrad challenges
hilf mir actions oder auf blogs
allerdings kann ich wirklich sagen dass
dieses jahr bisher für mich das
krasseste ja auf youtube war gerade auch
aufgrund des lounges der luca pizza 2
allerdings wären nichts von dem ganzen
möglich gewesen ohne euch deswegen
freunde ihr seht ihr schon und titel
eingeblendet einfach nur danke ich
wollte mich einfach mal bei euch dafür
bedanken dass sie mich dieses ganze jahr
über so tatkräftig unterstützt hat bei
vielen aktionen kann sich die sonne
verpassen um mit euren support meine ich
nicht nur den kauf meiner klamotten oder
der luca platz 2 oder so sondern auch
einfach solche sachen wie videos
einsenden für lukas noll stunde
kommentare oder auch einen daumen hoch
geben
bei videos allein in diesem jahr wurden
dem handy videos über 10 millionen mal
der daumen hoch button gedrückt habe ich
mir natürlich gedanken gemacht hey wie
kann ich euch das in irgendeiner form
zurückgeben und letztes jahr habe ich ja
materielle gegenstände verlost wie
beispielsweise handys oder
spielekonsolen dieses jahr habe ich mich
allerdings mit dem kumpel formieren
damit star hier zusammen gesetzt und wir
haben ein best-of luca 2018
zusammengestellt in dem die unserer
meinung nach besten videos sehen meine
des kanals in diesem jahr
zusammengefasst wurden und ja freunde
frohe weihnachten und filme
dieser konnte sie dort umgekommen sein
kontrakt ist es doch was ist 12 geteilt
durch 3 -4
richtig diese ukulele wichtig wieso
gibt's die denn jetzt tim luca mich ein
schock ist schon witze harris und
alabaster er ist und sie hat mir klicks
kann man so vielleicht nicht morgen
schon seit juli
[Musik]
juli auf dem zweiten zettel steht heidi
klum also endlich war ich auf dem
parkett die heidi heidi klum küssen
alex ist schon heiraten und sich
umbringen
ja klar direkt fotos stadt erfasst der
pause schon gemacht
[Musik]
ich schwöre euch wieder diesen
supermarkt gehen und daran zu denken
[Applaus]
wenn du hast ja dead money for the
weekend take up ist das alltag
das ist unser boden auf dem boden bleibt
30 kartons und fitness kanal auf machen
willst du mit mir zusammen leute leute
der clever bot film mit mir zusammen
sein ich liebe dich auch also wir sind
jetzt wirklich in einer beziehung
zusammen wunderbar also willst du auch
kinder mit mir dass er ist sehr schnell
auf den punkt gekommen ich hab nix oder
fanpage grit thümmel die mit 1000
abonnenten
ich erzähle hergerichtet
danke für dein lag auf meinem foto hat
mir echt mega viel bedeutet
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was drin
ich glaube dass wirklich drin mithilfe
jule und ich selten seite wechseln
verfügen wurden im boden geworden fasst
erster spieler melden
der hefepilz gekillt doch anstatt in ein
natel weiß ich in die 1
alter schwede katja klubobmann das leben
klar dass diese autofahrer als er die
tut mir leid aber wollen die mich
verarschen wo sind die denn alle
was soll denn diese mache jetzt
macht man sich ja dieses spiel wenn das
bei euch klappt dann verkaufe ich meine
unterhose bei ebay.de mich komplett
verarschen
[Musik]
da 133 1300 euro erwarten
wir müssen schauen sie die kraft aus dem
takt bringen das jedoch klar jetzt
[Musik]
was vom küssen um mich jetzt einfach so
was knallhart
[Musik]
über das alter das ich mir war
ihr befreundet doch bei den nun
eingeräumt bitte nicht den kern dieses
etikett muss für rückgabe und umtausch
gefestigt bleiben unter zitiert mit
bügel insolvenz nicht mehr breite und
acht euro und bild und der boden roten
flecken die lupe zur zweiten juventus
turin
ich muss diesen hund wie mich selbst
beschützen und herunter und beschattet
wir müssen wir klug wir müssen wirklich
nehmen die karre lassi karonen schnell
sehr gut trainiert weil eben schnell
schnell nicht so überlaufen nein nein
als ob es keine wirklich passiert
[Musik]
so wie jetzt schön hätte werden jetzt
auch was passiert hier stelle ich jetzt
war da redet jetzt mal das finale video
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich langsam um um schreibst du denn da
ich zitiere jude von beginnen nicht in
die richtung dass der baum aber hinter
sein genau langsam 300 das für 300 euro
140 euro plus 65 euro so lange warten
[Musik]
nicht wahr darf doch die schweiz für
doch jetzt nicht auf meinen boden
[Musik]
als ich das erste mal geguckt habe sind
nicht so leicht die tränen gekommen so
viele krasse sachen sind einfach
passiert sie nur aufgrund von euch nur
wegen euch das ist eigentlich krass
einig könnte man den kanal euch ich will
jetzt gar nicht so eine übels
euphorische und epische dankesrede
halten sondern ich möchte einfach nur
sagen danke ich glaube damit das alles
gesagt ihr seid schon echt top mit
ich möchte das gar nicht
das sagen ja dieses jahr war erst der
anfang und 2019 wird richtig eskaliert
und blabla ich habe mir natürlich wieder
auch in diesem urlaub hier also ihr seht
schon etwas andere kulisse
ich bin in österreich mit meiner familie
ich nutze die zeit hier immer um mich
den ganzen tag mit brainstorming zu
beschäftigen
also was ich auf meinem kanal verbessern
könnte und was für neue serien nicht
eventuell machen könnte im neuen jahr
auf jeden fall schon einige neue video
ideen zusammen sammeln können in diesem
urlaub also seid gespannt was 2009 10
auf euch zukommen wird die videos für
die nächsten tage für den ersten
weihnachtsfeiertag also jetzt für den 25
bis zum 31 sind alle bereits produziert
also ihr habt dieses jahr auf jeden fall
noch jeden tag video von mir und 100g
2009/10 frisch los wenn ich wieder
zurück in köln bin und wider von meinem
pc sitze da bekomme ich auch endlich mal
neuen pc das heißt ich kann auch mehr
streamen wird auch ein neues thema sein
dass 2019 kommen wird mit musik da werde
ich meine fortschritte endlich mal
öffentlich machen da bilde ich mich ja
mittlerweile seit gefühlten jahren
weiter allerdings ja meine damen und die
das war richtig los ich würde das video
der stelle jetzt auch beenden
ich glaube diese perspektive wird 2009
auch ein bisschen öfter kommen ich
wollte mich mal wieder mehr flocken ich
wollte einfach mal ganz ganz fett danke
sagen an euch meine damen und herren
dieses jahr war unfassbar krass es ist
so viel passiert und ich glaube ich
wiederhole mich gerade die ganze zeit
ihr wisst was die messages von diesem
video die steht nämlich auch im titel
danke lu crew für dieses jahr 2019 und
da geht's weiter also eigentlich sehen
uns erstmal morgen weil ich aber noch
ein video produzieren
[Musik]